wo- WOAH! WOAAH!
IIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII
Didn't know this was here
heeeeeeeeRRRRRe
Whuuuh the fuuuuck
GASP
What the fuuuck?!
WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT?!?
THAT'S COOOOL!
OH MY GOD
I did not know this was here
Holy shit...
Whhhhat
I'm gonna die
But this is AWESOME
ERMEH GAWD
PUT THIS IN MATT
MATT! PUT THIS IN
MAT-PUT IT IIIN!!!
It's all going dark
AHDAUGHDAUGH
DAGUHAHWAGHHD
ARGARGUEH
OK
Anyway..
OKAY!!
SO that was new!
I had no idea that was there
Hello everybody! My name is
Markiplier
And welcome back to
Subnautica
That was
the abandoned sea base
I did not know
That was there
I HONESTLY didn't!
I have no idea how to get back there without warping
but I will get to that in just a second
the first thing that I have to do
is get a Seamoth
There we go!
Yes! Ok!
The only reason I'm cheating here
is because I'm in experimen- AAAHOHOHEHOH
WHOA
HEY
WHOAA
Hello !
Okay then
That is bizarre
I am dying cause this one can't take the pressure
but I just need to be able to see...
Wait, item tank, ok
I just need to be able to see
where to get in
this thing
and it looks like
oh man
this is bad
Oh there we go! Right there, okay
So that's the entrance for me
So before this blows up I'm going right in
cause we don't have a lot of time
and I gotta see what's going on here
I've never been here before
Ooh. What did that do?
PDA
Photo album
Log
"You've been too long in the midnight sea"
that... doesn't help me
Really
It didn't do anything, it didn't say anything
apparently that PDA was just bust
but hopefully in the future that's gonna have something
and that's one of the new machines!
This is experimental mode so
there's a lot of things that aren't... exactly in the...
main game just yet
That was another PDA.
So, not everything is implemented here
but it's suuuper cool that this is all here
Just look at this!
This is in the middle of a goddamn ocean
Why did they build it in the purple mushroom caverns
This is like, in the caverns beneath everything
and... obviously I haven't seen any of this before
and that's because
it wasn't here before
This is all new
All these PDAs, I can't even touch that PDA
because I'm PASSING OUT
BAAAAAH! Okay.
There we go
Thank you, I guess
Ok, so what I'm gonna do is
I need to get to the island
which is the staging ground of where I'm gonna do
this next thing
I'm going to shOW you guys
The Sea Emperor
The Sea Dragon
which is a different version of the Emperor
and some other creatures
if I can get them to work
but to do that I need a place
I can go and spawn them
without immediately being killed by them
cause I don't know if they're gonna be active at all
Let's test it out first
Ooh to be back in my little Seamoth
it may not be the USS F**KADUCK
but it's still pretty cool
I'm gonna ram it!
UAH take this Sancho!
I've had enough of you UAAH
Oow sorry...
I don't even know if I can kill you
[Clang]
Haha
Can I kill you?
I have no idea
[Clang] Ow
I'll be honest, i've never really tried
Aah, you know what? You're a peaceful giant, I ain't gonna bother you
You do alright
You do you
I'll leave you alone
Unless those just broke its spine
I just doomed it to be MURDERED by a Reaper Leviathan down the road
[Sigh]
There's still something just horrifically
Terrifying
A- and
Is it just me or is it more obscure?
Like the sun shafts n' stuff like
it seems like they added a bit more detail to this but i'm not 100% sure because I never
like whenever i'm in the ocean
I lose a sense of everything that i've seen the last time I was in the ocean
I literally have NO idea
what to expect down below the waves
At least i've found the floating isle
And on the floating isle I shall start
summoning DEMONS
the likes of which you've never seen. >:]
Uh-oh!
Wrong, this isn't the beach!
Ow!
Good thing this Sea Moth is expendable.
sploosh (◕ᴥ◕)
Oh no!
Where is my castle?
Shieett
Alright anyway
Oh I need the knife
Whoa, hello
What're you?
Scanner room? What's a scanner ROOM?
I don't know what a scanner room is but it sounds AWESOME.
So there's a lot of new stuff in experimental mode and
the next few episodes that I make will actually BE in experimental mode, because
[crab sound]
There's so much more to see and there's so much more to be done
when they're constantly releasing updates to the game
So you guys will see that in the future but for right now
I'm just gonna test something real quick
Okay
So to test something, i'm gonna stand right here
on the edge of the ocean
And i'm going to spawn
Just to test it
Cause this is something that we've already encountered
[Pop]
WHOA, HEY, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA
Whooaaaa, whoa
I didn't expect it to spawn directly on top of me!
GOD, you're huuuuuge! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
What the ffUUCCkk
Ah, stop it, i'm trying to look at something here.
Jeezums, good golly
What is it doing?
Staaaahp.
Stop being a little BUTT
Oh my god, you're such crap
there we go
Alright, you're dead
I don't know where the Reap--
I looked away for just a second and it's gone
Should I jump in?
Oh, jumping in would be a bad idea
Where'd it go?
Where the HELL did it go?
OH oh, there it is! o-o
Whoaa-ho-ho
Oh man, it's just living its own life now
Ok
So
I'm going to be summoning in things in a certain order because I wanna see
Uh, exactly what they do
Uh,  before I do it
And the next thing i'm gonna be doing--
I'm gonna build up, i'm gonna build up to it
So i'm gonna be warping in something called...
"The Warper" oddly enough
Hallo
Okay, so this thing is..
EEUUGGHH
Are they gonna fight?!
I probably should--
Ooogh.
AAAAHHH!!
Oh, I think they fought. Holy shit
Okay
ooOOHH you're so big! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Eh
let me get some of ya (     ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°   )
[Manly scream]
Oh god
that's so scary
Eh, go away please
I'm just waiting for it to grab onto me
With his big meATY clAWS
BIG
MEATY
CLAAWWSSS
I wonder if I can ram it with my Seamoth
Maybe that'll be a good use of the Seamoth!
Op, nevermind
It's- it's stuck
Herp
Ah shet
Well something just got eaten
Or else it just shat out its last meal
Okay, so let me try that again
Warper...
Okay, so the warper..
is
a creature that actually su-- uh
Summons portals that will teleport you around
It's not fully implemented, obviously
but
It's just an interesting creature and a good step up from the Reaper Leviathan
but i've made a problem for myself with that thing
BYE!
Wow. OH! That's what it does,
That's what it was !
It just teleported!
Coool.
Anyway, ok, so
the next one is the mesmer
Mesmer...
And the mesmer is actually a small fish
that supposedly, when it's done,
it'll stare at you, and then...
Oh there it is! There it is, it's doing it!
It pulls you in and then it steals health
UHEEEY you pull me in and steal way more health
NOOO!
My Seamoth!
Youuuu son of a bitch
Give it back!
I'm gonna slice and dice ya
Okay, well, that's a lost cause
Goodbyyye
Have fun- WOW
I think I just saw a piece of it explode off into the hills
So that was cool!
Oh that guy's a dick
Alright
So and if I spawn more than one mesmer
They will have staring contests with each other
How cool is that?!
Like, literally they'll just, they'll have little staring constests
they'll be like
HEY! Heyuh what are you doin'
hey what are you doin'
hey, hey
uh oh
Aah! I'm drawned in by their gaaaze
He's a comin'
AAAAH!
OH HE GOT ME
WELL THAT'S UH- FUCK
Goddammit
They sped that up quick
Holy shit
Oookie dokie then
Wuh oh.
Wheeewuhwuhwheweewho
Where am I going?
Aaaaaah...
ShiiiiT
Not where I wanted to be
Welp.This is a problem.
uh, I seem to have warped into the wrong location.
ugh don't touch me with your squiggly tentacles
There we go, okay.
That's much better.
Oh and I get this PDA now
even though the PDAs don't seem to be working
AH GOOD, FOOD
Yes please
Alright.
So now,
that we're up on this mountain top
I'm going to spawn another Reaper Leviathan
and I'm gonna see what it does on land.
HELLO
HI
WELCOME TO THE PARTY
What are you doing?
*laughs in the goofiest way*
Ooh there it goes
it just goes right through the floor, straight into the water
You know what, good for it
I just made another one
that's gonna be even more of a problem for me
Okay.
The next thing that I'm gonna do is actually the next step up
on the way to the Emperor.
And the Emperor
*blows* it scares me
Alright here we go !
Here we go, spawn Sea Dragon...
*pop*
WOAAH OHOHOHOH
*laughs in French*
Oh my god
Helloooo
Hi friend!
He's got the dopey- oh my god
Do a backflip brah niiice
Well, woah, shit
This guy......
he's not having a good time right now
He is stuck on the beach and he can't go anywhere
Oh my god that's th- uhuh
*laughs honhon baguette*
Something tells me this one isn't implemented properly
HELLOW
Let me end it- wow I'm gonna ride you apparently
Let me end your suffering bruh
Oh good I pushed off into the deeee-ugh uh oh
AOW?! 80% of my life, gone, like that
Alrighty then!
Good for me!
Well that guy's just so happy and free~~~
Oh that's adorable
OH are they gonna fight?
I hope they fight- OKAY
So either way, that's both of them
but the...
Emperor...
needs a special place
That's the Sea Dragon
which is about the same size as the Reaper Leviathan by the looks of it
just a little, not a 100% with it, mentally
but, that doesn't matter because we're not gonna judge him like that
He still hurts like a son of a bitch
So the next one that we're gonna do
needs a special place
an isolated coast
not to be bothered by anybody else
because he is a reclusive
King of the Sea...
Ah let's do this
I'm actually gonna do this in the ocean
*exhales loudly*
Here we go
OHUHOUHWOW
WHAT THE FUCK
WHOAA WHOAA WHOAA
HIIII
HOOOLY SHIT
I should have got- I'm getting out of the ocean
uuhokaaaay
AAAH!
He ate me
He ate me up
He ate me good
He, he done ate- he, he ated me
Okay, now that we're back on the island
and I have a bit of a perch with which to watch
and not die
hopefully anyway
Let's get a good look at this son of a bitch
uh I mean ~~Majestic King of the Ocean~~
HELLOO
Woooooh
Helloo- wooahohoh
you're gonna come up and say hi to- wooohoh
Way to dive bomb into the ocean there
but at least you're swimming free
Oh my god
Now obviously
not a 100% working yet
The animations aren't all there
the behavior isn't all there
uh I mean the Reaper Leviathan is able to
coil and move and actually look like it's swimming properly
in the ocean; that, that looks more like
That looks more like he's having a seizure in the middle of the ocean
but that's beside the point
That is...
the Sea Emperor
and I'm gonna spawn next to him
eeem, spawn Sea Dragon
boink :3
eeeeeeeeeeeh~
sploooosh
They have kinda the same
uh...
back? (baby got back)
Like their tentacles are actually kinda similar
and their bio-luminescence are actually kinda similar too
so they may be related in term of a species
of a hypothetical game
but it's just interesting to see, so
and then, the last thing that I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna spawn a bunch of
Reaper Leviathans
See, these things are elegant
and... and let me just do
ten of these
WOOOOH WOHOHO woHO wohO
I shot him of into space
boink
*witchy laugh*
WOOHOOO~
YEAH!
okay byyye
have fun
oh that one's, wooh
WELL,
I've just populated the entire ocean with just
endless amounts of Reaper Leviathans
Hello friend
how are you doing
God it's so huge
so but apparently,
and I don't know if that's the final size
of how these things are gonna be but the Reaper Leviathan
actually looks bigger than the other things
like the Sea Emperor and the Sea Dragon
I've never seen it before so I had no idea of what the comparison would actually be
but there you have it
that is
what I have to show you
It's not done yet,
obviously, and in the next episode
we're gonna be exploring a lot of very
early stage stuff
but it's gonna be exciting nonetheless
UUHAH!
WHY?
How'd you do that?
Who did that?
Who did that? I have no idea
Please stay away
But it's gonna be interesting
it's gonna be dangerous
and it's gonna be a lot of fun
So I hope you'll enjoy it, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see ~you~
in the next video
buh bye!
[OUTRO MUSIC]